Ah, thankfully novelist was my number one,
took a while though.
Again, I worked for a couple decades nearly,
and at some point it really wasn't my goal
to become a novelist anymore.
I loved my work at the time developing software
and then I went back to it.
So, I think the thing I'd say to people is
sometimes it's a very circuitous path.
I mean, I wouldn't change it in hindsight
how it happened.
I mean, I finally got to my dream profession,
but the journey was enjoyable too,
and that's what I would say.
It was definitely novelist,
I think really only that.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.